[MUSIC - REGINA SPEKTOR, "YOU'VE
GOT TIME"]
[MUSIC - JAMIE N. COMMONS AND X
AMBASSADORS, "JUNGLE"]
SAM: I like what you've
done with the place.
PIPER: Sadly, it's starting
to feel like home in here.
CRAZY EYES: Three, two, one, go!
[CHEER]
BROOKE: This is not how I
imagined prison to be at all.
CINDY: [SINGING] Oh!
TIFFANY AND PIPER: Yay!
GALINA: A woman I
knew a long time ago
came back in yesterday.
CRAZY EYES: Ooh.
VEE: I know.
CRAZY EYES: Who are you?
VEE: I'm Vee.
ROSA: You've got
something to say to me?
PIPER: This place is bull--
SISTER INGALLS:
There's a storm coming.
BOTH: What!
VEE: Boom, boom, boom!
BIG BOO: Ooh!
PIPER: I am lone wolf.
And a vicious one.
Don't make me rip
your throat out.
CINDY: That's what
I'm talking about!
CHELSEY KANTOR: Hi, everyone.
I'm Chelsey Kantor
from the Google+ team.
And I'm here with three of
the amazing cast members
from the recently Critic
Choice-nominated for Best
Comedy Series, "Orange
is the New Black."
Let's give it up.
NATASHA LYONNE: Thank you.
UZO ADOBA: Thank you.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
Starting on the end,
we have the lovely Miss Uzo
Adoba, Suzanne "Crazy Eyes"
Warren.
And in the middle, we have
Natasha Lyonne, Miss Nicky
Nichols.
And to my right, the one and
only Yael Stone, Morello.
So I'm going to kick it ff here
with a few questions for each
of you, and then a
few for the group.
And then we'll open
it up to people
in the room that have burning
questions they want answered.
But I'm going to start with you.
And first congrats on your
nomination for the Critics
Choice Award for what?
Featured Comedic
Performer in a Series.
UZO ADOBA: Yes.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Did you know
you were in a comedy series?
UZO ADOBA: Good question.
You know, no-- yeah, I think
there was this great balance
that Jenji-- Jenji Kohan
who created our show--
has managed to
keep with the show.
And I personally feel that in
order for the world of comedy,
as I've heard Natasha say
and countless others say,
that in order for that
world to really exist,
you have to balance it
well with the drama.
And the circumstance of
where we are, that in itself
helps to set the
tone of the drama.
But you know, tampons
in a McMuffin are funny.
And peeing on the
floor is funny.
NATASHA LYONNE: And tragic.
UZO ADOBA: And tragic.
Exactly.
It's a balance there.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
Tragically funny.
UZO ADOBA: That's right.
It's tragically funny.
That's exactly right.
CHELSEY KANTOR: So the world
got to know you as Crazy Eyes,
but I first knew you through
"Godspell" on Broadway .
And then because of that, on
"Project Runway All Stars."
So tell me about the
transition from Broadway
and fashion to prison.
UZO ADOBA: Well, there is a
very clear fashion statement
in prison.
And it is that there is none.
No, but even in
the fashion though,
Jenn Rogien, who's
our costume designer,
does a really amazing
job with something
that's so uniform and singular
and finding unique touches
and nuances when you look
at everyone's costume,
to display an individuality
and personality within that.
But I think it's really
interesting whether it's
Poussey with the
sweatshirt, or if you
have my own costume
with the thumbs,
or Nicky with the
rolled-up sleeves,
everybody has a touch of
their outer self appearing
in their inner prison self,
which is kind of cool.
But going from
theater to television,
I thought it was going to be
this massive leap of a world
that I didn't
understand, just because
of the technical
elements of the medium.
But what I really
learned doing the show
was that good stories
are good stories.
If the story is good, my job as
the actor is made pretty easy.
And thankfully, the
writers on our show
have made my job
easier with their words
and have just been so
phenomenally brilliant
at crafting a story that I
could understand whether it's
on a stage of a theater or
on a sound stage of a studio.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
So I heard a story
that you went in to
audition for another part,
but then they offered
you Crazy Eyes.
So can you tell
us one, what part
that was, and what about your
audition, what they saw in you
made you perfect for
Miss Suzanne Warren?
UZO ADOBA: So sorry.
That's a good question that I
too would like the answer for.
I went in originally, I
went in and I auditioned
for the role of Janae,
who's played brilliantly
by Vicky Jeudy on our show.
She's done a phenomenal job with
it, and it's completely right
and makes sense for it.
I went and I read for that part,
and then I got a phone call
from my representation.
And they said, we have
really great news for you.
I said, OK, what?
What is it?
And they said, you
remember that audition
you went on for "Orange is
the New Black" this summer?
I said, yes, absolutely.
Because I remember
reading that script
and thinking to
myself of the things
that I had read that summer,
wow, that was really good.
I would love if I could be a
part of something like that.
That would be great.
And then continued on.
So when I got the
call, and they said,
you remember that audition
you went on for "Orange
is the New Black" this summer?
I said, yes!
Totally.
I absolutely remember.
They said, well,
you didn't get it.
I said, OK, what's the
good news that you--
you said there was good news?
And they said, but they'd like
to offer you another part.
And I said, amazing!
What's the other part?
And they were like Crazy Eyes.
And I was still like,
um, chicken and waffles,
like I don't know what
that means, you know,
like what is that?
But when I read the
script, it really
did feel like the right fit.
That just felt right.
CHELSEY KANTOR: So what about
her was already on the page,
and what do you think you
brought to that character?
UZO ADOBA: What was
already on the page?
I think, definitely the
essence of her truest essence,
which for me, I think,
is the innocence,
and her want and need
to give and get love
at it's fullest,
was certainly there.
There's a line in the second
episode of the script when
they're introducing Crazy Eyes.
Piper's coming into
the cafeteria in
and I'm paraphrasing it now, It
was written by Marco Ramirez,
but she's walking
into the cafeteria
and she's looking
for a place to sit.
And then she looks
right and there sitting
there is-- turn the
page-- Crazy Eyes.
And he had described
her as someone
who is innocent like a child,
except children aren't scary.
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought that
felt like the key
to the door that might
open this character,
because someone who is
innocent like a child,
to me meant that
somebody who operates out
of impulse, who operates,
who acts and then thinks.
Children don't have agendas.
They're not calculating.
They're not trying to
do something for gai.
They're just doing it
for the purity of it.
That animalistic survival
instinct of quality
within them.
So that was something.
But then whatever
it is that she's
doing though is not responded
to with the same affection
that it is when it is
a child is very clear.
And so I just started
having this vision
of that sort of-- she's
a [INAUDIBLE] adult woman
with a sledgehammer
and a pacifier.
That picture really came
to my brain, I said,
but that made sense to me.
But somebody who's just
trying to give and get
love-- it felt
like a love story.
That's all I could see
when I was reading it.
I said, of this is
somebody in the deepest
and most honest pursuit of love.
CHELSEY KANTOR: What
do you learn about her
in Season Two that you
didn't know is Season One.
UZO ADOBA: Hmm.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
And you can be as
specific or vague as you want.
UZO ADOBA: I will
choose the vague route.
No.
What did I learned
about her in Season Two
that I didn't know
about her in Season One?
How far she'll go for love.
I think I asked the
question of myself,
because when we're
doing Season One,
I was really interested in
the experiment of answering
how far does
someone go for love.
Would someone go for love.
In Season Two, I have
a piece or certainly
a scope of that answer.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Hmm.
Nice, little tease.
[LAUGHTER]
So one of the many things that
makes this show so viral role
and shareable is
its quotable nature.
And the one liners and
the scenes and memes
that they spawn
go across the web.
So I'd love to know what your
favorite Crazy Eyes quotable
quote is from Season One.
And if you can, one of your
favorites from Season Two.
So I know my favorite
from Season One.
UZO ADOBA: OK.
Your favorite?
CHELSEY KANTOR: I
know my favorite,
but I'd like to know yours.
UZO ADOBA: OK, my favorite from
Season One, my favorite quote,
I mean, how can you not love
"I threw my pie for you."
I just enjoy saying that.
That's what Crazy
Eyes says, but I
have some pretty favorite lines.
My personal favorite lines
are actually not the lines
that I say.
I actually really love the line
that Sophia, played by Laverne
Cox, says "please is for
hoes and Oliver Twist."
I don't know why I
think that's hilarious.
Every single time I hear
it, I think it's hilarious.
I just think it's hilarious
every time I hear it.
CHELSEY KANTOR: I think we'd all
like to hear a little (SINGING)
"Chocolate and vanilla--
CHELSEY & UZO: Swirl, swirl.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Thank you.
UZO ADOBA: You're welcome.
CHELSEY KANTOR: And from Season
Two, is there a favorite yet?
UZO ADOBA: From Season Two?
Do I have a favorite
line from Season Two?
NATASHA LYONNE: Be careful now.
UZO ADOBA: I know.
I'm thinking, I'm thinking.
I really like line
"Three, two, one, go."
[LAUGHTER]
With no tone put behind
it, so you don't know--
CHELSEY KANTOR: I have no idea.
UZO ADOBA: I could be
like, three, two, one, go?
Three, two, one, go!
Like it could mean anything.
Yeah.
Three, two one, go.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Thank
you for that, at least.
UZO ADOBA: You're welcome.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
This small piece.
Natasha?
NATASHA LYONNE: Yah.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Hi.
I would love to talk to you.
So, lot of people here probably
know you from "American Pie."
But you've had an
incredible career
starting with "Pee
Wee's Playhouse."
NATASHA LYONNE: I'm going to
need something caffeinated.
I can tell.
CHELSEY KANTOR: And a major
role with Woody Allen.
And where I fell
in love with you
which is "Slums
of Beverly Hills."
NATASHA LYONNE: Thank you.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
Because it has quite
possibly two of my
favorite scenes in a film.
One, can you tell us what
it's like to stab someone
with a fork?
NATASHA LYONNE:
Yeah, I don't know.
I've never-- really done that.
Who do I stab?
Carl Reiner?
I think it's Carl Reiner, right?
CHELSEY KANTOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
NATASHA LYONNE: Yeah, Yeah.
That was an exciting day.
Carl Reiner, and Rita
Moreno and Alan Arkin, that
was amazing, that day.
CHELSEY KANTOR: And
then two, can you just
talk gibberish with
me for a second?
NATASHA LYONNE: Oh.
Here we go.
Says really, you know, I'm
not as young as I used to be.
So it's like 20 years ago.
Yes, go ahead.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Hit a guy, hit
a guy, what a gar you to gyoo.
NATASHA LYONNE: Et a
guy, I'm f'ta guine.
Gibberish.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Gibberish.
I can say, yit a goo,
ketagam fit a geet mitagee.
NATASHA LYONNE:
Oh, I complete you.
That's so kind of you.
CHELSEY KANTOR: You're welcome.
NATASHA LYONNE: I
have to say, I'm
almost teetering on concerned.
But I'm also pleased to
hear it and grateful to you.
Thank you.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Because
one of my things
that I love about this show
are the little inside cultural
references that are made, like
with you and Kate Mulgrew,
when you say the line
about being her Spock
or with Jason Biggs,
making an American Pie
reference to webcam horror
in a shaving incident.
NATASHA LYONNE: Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Should we
expect more cultural references
in this show?
Is that part of what makes it--
NATASHA LYONNE: I don't recall,
is my honest answer for you.
I know what you're
talking about.
OK?
So I'm hearing you.
[LAUGHTER]
I just honestly
don't remember which
ones were-- I'm sure--
there's another one.
The one I remember is like
there is an exorcist bit, right?
Is it your mother sucks cocks?
Can you say that?
I think right when
I'm talking to Mattie
on the-- about
kicking the-- right?
There was something about the
drugs and the exorcist happens.
And then I was also in "Scary
Movie 2," the Linda Blair part.
So it's like the
inside within inside,
inside of a Russian doll.
Deep, deep, inside
of a Russian doll.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Deep inside.
NATASHA LYONNE: Yes.
But I don't remember
what happens.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Tell
me a little bit more
about your relationship
with Kate Mulgrew.
Because it's a great
part of the show.
Nicky has such a troubled
relationship with her mom,
and Red serves as kind
of this surrogate mother.
Will that relationship continue
to be important in Season Two?
And will we see it change?
NATASHA LYONNE:
Yeah, absolutely, it
continues to be important.
And it changes.
I like whatever's
happening over here.
It's exciting.
And I adore Kate Mulgrew.
I mean she's got to be
one of my favorite people
I've ever worked with.
She's so present and
forces you to kind
of like elevate the
quality of-- you
just can't lie to Kate Mulgrew.
You feel like you would
be called out in a second,
like she'd almost
like stop the scene
and be like (RUSSIAN
ACCENT) this is nothing.
This is dirt.
You can't give me
something better.
Whatever.
And obviously, I really
should have done that role,
as you can see by how excellent
that portrayal of Red was.
And then, of course, when
she does break character,
I mean she is like a deeply
funny human being, Kate
Mulgrew, and just so talented,
but also like so filthy.
And so like between
the sex and the fear,
it's really a joy
to work with her.
She's really one of a kind.
And certainly, yes, that
is true of Nicky Nichols
has deep mommy troubles, and
how great that in Kate, she
really gets that figure and
doesn't want to disappoint her,
and yet, Kate's whole--
Red's whole trip
is kind of called into question
by the end of Season One.
And obviously, there's a fall
out of that in Season Two.
And so our
relationship continues
to be sort of like complicated
and grounded in a deeper love,
but also impacted by prison
politics, which is actually
the whole political
arena, prison politics.
UZO ADOBA: Yes.
NATASHA LYONNE: Yeah, you can
be like president or whatever.
I'm sorry.
I'm with you.
You complete me.
CHELSEY KANTOR: You complete me.
You made my life.
Another kind of compelling
relationship for Nicky Nichols
is the one she has with Morello.
There's an attraction there.
What do you think it is about
her that intrigues her so much?
I think that--
YAEL STONE: Should I go?
NATASHA LYONNE: I
think that-- no, it's
just we're taking turns.
You are next.
CHELSEY KANTOR: You are next.
NATASHA LYONNE: You just be
pati-- have some Diet Coke.
YAEL STONE: No, I just meant
if you wanted to be honest--
NATASHA LYONNE: No, no, no, oh!
Oh.
Here you go.
YAEL STONE: I should go,
so you can be honest.
NATASHA LYONNE: So
here's what I think.
I think that as far as my prison
wife goes, I'm in the room.
OK, so as far as they
my prison wife goes,
I think that basically
Nicky is so cynical
and kind of like
been there seen,
that, gotten high,
seen the world,
comes from sort of like
this rich background
that she's kind of pretending
she doesn't in order to play
the tough guy in prison
and not get shanked.
And I think that in
Lorna, she finds--
Lorna's so sweet and
pure and racist--
[LAUGHTER]
And I mean, in many
ways a very problematic,
morally problematic character.
And yet, there's something
about her that feels so sweet.
And part of what's insane about
her sort of casual racism in
and prison is that
she's like genuinely
doing it from a place of
not knowing that she's even
in the wrong, like your
whole "West Side Story"
bit and whatever.
It's like she doesn't know
that she's saying crazy shit.
And I think that for Nicky,
who is deeply aware of all
of that kind of stuff,
there's something
that feels very much like
if this girl likes me,
she means it, versus my mother
who's playing a head game
and is on some
manipulative trip.
Like, if this girl's
spending time with me,
she's just not a liar.
You know what I mean?
Even though she
wants Christopher
more than she wants
me, the fact that she's
choosing me means she
actually-- and so I
think that that kind
of underlying truth
is at least what I've
worked out of why Nicky like
craves Morello so
much versus any
of the other women in prison
who may want to be with Nicky
more than Lorna actually does.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Does that
continue in Season Two?
NATASHA LYONNE:
[SNIFFS] I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA LYONNE: I have
no way of knowing.
It's-- uh-- well, Yael, does
that continue in Season Two?
CHELSEY KANTOR: Yael,
let's chat a little bit.
YAEL STONE: I just want to
establish just that I didn't
mean should I go because
you were talking,
I just meant should I go
because you were going to talk
about us, and I wanted you to
be honest, rather than feel
you had to say nice
things about Morello.
NATASHA LYONNE: Listen,
I feel like Nicky
has nothing negative
to say about Lorna.
I feel like Lorna
has some issues
to work out around
Nicky, that that's
potentially what's hurtful.
You know?
Because I'm always
showing up for you,
and you're always
like oh, Christopher.
Fucking Christopher, right?
I mean, it's like enough
already with the Christopher.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Let's just
meet Christopher already.
NATASHA LYONNE: Is
this a PG thing.
I realize I just want
to check in real quick.
CHELSEY KANTOR: It will be
when we repost it later.
NATASHA LYONNE: OK.
Tone down for once.
CHELSEY KANTOR: So let's
talk, Yael, about Lorna's
relentlessly hopeful
nature and where
you feel like that comes from.
YAEL STONE: Probably in prison.
Probably a place of
being under real strain.
I think that that's when
we really reach the hottest
and really create the most
detailed fantasies about how
things are going to be good.
Because it's tough.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Preservation.
YAEL STONE: Yeah.
And along with that comes
the hair and the makeup.
Because it's like I gotta keep
it together, keep it together.
Everything's fine.
I think in opposition to that
is a really genuine relationship
there and a really
nice engagement
that's going on between them.
But the other stuff is like
I'm OK, I'm OK, I'm OK,
I mean, I'm OK, I'm OK, right?
Right?
I'm OK, I'm OK.
Which I have definitely felt
myself and definitely seen
in other people.
And it's like turned
up to 11, because she's
in some really
dire circumstance.
I also think Lorna is
a pretty good player
in that political game.
She's seemingly very ignorant,
and she is, in certain areas,
but she can play.
She knows how to keep safe.
She knows how to be
under the right wing.
As soon as Madeline Brewer's
character comes back
from her whole
detoxing situation,
she goes to hug her
and embrace her again.
And Reds like, nuh-uh, we're
not friends with her anymore,
and it's dropped.
It's gone.
She just drops her
sister like that.
Because she needs to keep safe.
And I think that's what's
so strong about this show,
the stakes are really high.
You can get hurt.
You can be iced out.
You can be starved.
I think that's the
success of the show
that the stakes are
like always up here.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Do you think
that's why she resists Nicky,
because she has to play the game
smart and not with her heart?
Or do you think she
genuinely is still
holding out for Christopher?
YAEL STONE: I think that
there's a tension, what's
really interesting about her,
and interesting about a lot
of us as human
beings, is there's
a tension between our fantasy
life and our real life.
And sometimes we compromise
decisions by gripping on tight
to that fantasy.
And I suspect that's
what's going on with her.
But that relationship
is always twisting
and changing and turning.
CHELSEY KANTOR: So
everyone in the room
can tell she is
not from Brooklyn.
She is Australian.
And the accent you've
adopted for Morello
has been called the
best accent on TV.
So, bravo.
YAEL STONE: Oh my goodness.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
But it's sort of--
YAEL STONE: Who said that?
UZO ADOBA: The woman.
CHELSEY KANTOR:
There was a vote.
It's sort of gangster-film noir.
You said it's sort of
inspired by Adelaide
from "Guys and Dolls."
Is that right?
YAEL STONE: Did I
really say that?
UZO ADOBA: I love it.
NATASHA LYONNE: (SINGING) A
person can develop a cold.
I don't know where it came.
I think there's a joy
in being an outsider
and being able to see a
culture in a different way.
We, as Australians, we consume
a lot of American stuff.
We mainline it.
It's saturation!
So there's a sense
of being an outsider,
but really having an
intimate knowledge
of an American
culture, and I guess
there's some parts
of that culture
that I've really
been fascinated by,
and I think it's very-- it
would be very fair to say this,
like a pastiche of sounds from
film-- definitely from films.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Definitely.
So we know that Uzo can sing.
And you have a musical family.
And your brother's in a
band called Blue Juice,
and you sang with them
before and your equally
musical sister.
Will there be any singing
on "Orange is the New Black"
with this musical cast?
YAEL STONE: I can't sing.
I'm terrible.
In fact, in Season
Two, there's moments
of really making fun of me.
And in Season One, like that
Christmas pageant thing?
UZO ADOBA: Yes.
YAEL STONE: Uzo did
the ice skating.
That was weird.
UZO ADOBA: Yeah.
YAEL STONE: Natasha did that
joke about the eggplant.
That was almost
weird and very funny.
And I sang (HIGH-PITCHED
VOICE) very high.
I'm not a good singer.
I'm terrible.
But she-- wow.
UZO ADOBA: Well, we have a
lot of people in the company--
CHELSEY KANTOR: That can sing.
UZO ADOBA: Who can sing.
Samira Wiley sings beautifully.
Danielle sings
phenomenally well.
NATASHA LYONNE: Annie Golden.
UZO ADOBA: Annie Golden!
Annie Golden is a-- she
was in the T-Shirts,
like in a real punk band.
CHELSEY KANTOR: So
musical episode?
NATASHA LYONNE: Lea Delaria.
UZO ADOBA: Lea Delaria.
Lea Delaria--
CHELSEY KANTOR: Scat machine.
UZO ADOBA: A
beautiful jazz singer.
CHELSEY KANTOR: We need to
see this in the episodes.
YAEL STONE: Well, I mean, the
end of Season One was really--
CHELSEY KANTOR: The talent show.
YAEL STONE: It was incredible.
That day, when we
shot-- when they
were doing the "Amazing
Grace" was just like-- crying.
Crying, take after
take after take.
It was the most beautiful thing.
UZO ADOBA: Yes.
YAEL STONE: Incredible
way to finish that.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Speaking
of the whole company,
and this question's
for all of you,
the show goes through
flashbacks for most
of the prisoners, which are a
brilliant way to kind of create
these fully-formed characters,
not defined by their crimes
or their race or
even their gender.
So which so far has been
your favorite back story?
And which should we look
forward to this season?
NATASHA LYONNE: Ladies?
UZO ADOBA: It's hard to pick
a favorite, specifically,
just to land on one,
because I think they all
offer such a different
cross section of what
the show is about.
You get to see-- I think what
you just said is so right on.
What's so amazing is we get
to encounter each character
for who they are, not what
they've done necessarily.
And what it is that
not by the crime,
but what emotional traumas that
they've been predisposed to
or encountered in
whatever situation be it,
Vicky's character
Janae-- what somebody
would do for love in part
or be it the absent mother
in Nicky Nichol's story or
Red and her family dynamic,
with the dynamic between
herself and her husband.
Or Sophia and her back story,
watching that family dynamic
play out.
So it's hard to
land on just one,
because I feel each story
is so fruitful and full
of so many different aspects
of the human condition.
NATASHA LYONNE: I will say
without saying anything
about what's coming
up, having read
the scripts, this season is
really exciting, especially
to already know the characters
and then to know them
as people, that now we've gotten
to spend some time together
is really-- it gets
deep this year.
And so the favorites
or whatever.
I always feel almost like
the show is sort of like
if "Roshomon" and
"The Wire" had a baby.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA LYONNE: The
whole idea of there's
my version of events,
your version of events,
and the truth.
And there's also this idea
of the scope of the show,
of like if you rack focus,
that person like way back there
in the corner who is
just a witness actually
is like the main
part of the story.
And what's so amazing of
this show is the scope.
It's just like if
you pulled back,
like we thought the
focus was over here.
And then that thing that you
saw passing by the frame that
was like fascinating but
gone is now the centerpiece.
And there's a lot
of that that happens
this season, where like
the people that you fell
in love with, it gets in much
deeper, and in hilarious--
like there's one person's
story I'm thinking of, like
[INAUDIBLE WHISPER].
UZO ADOBA: Oh, yes, yes.
NATASHA LYONNE:
Like her story is
going to be fucking hilarious.
UZO ADOBA: Yes.
NATASHA LYONNE: And-- sorry.
Hilarious.
[LAUGHTER] And then
there's like other stories
that are going to be
like really heavy duty.
And it's going to be a
very fun, fun year ever.
I'm like and then it'll kind of
like flesh out the whole thing.
It's just like it's
an (YOGI BEAR VOICE)
ever-deepening experience.
UZO ADOBA: Deeper.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Deeper.
So we encourage people--
UZO ADOBA: I don't know why I
said it like that, but jinx.
Because we said it
at the same time.
CHELSEY KANTOR: We
encourage people online
to submit questions.
I know we have
questions in the room.
So I'm going to ask you guys
to head to the microphone
to line up to ask those.
And while they're doing that--
NATASHA LYONNE: To the
window, to the wall.
CHELSEY KANTOR: I wanted to
get your guys' take on another
topic that's been heavily
discussed on Google+ and across
the web over the past week.
So the show's received
a lot of accolades
for representing women
and relationships
in a real, true way, not based
on convenient stereotypes
or cookie cutter things.
And that's always
been important.
But it seems even more
important in light
of the recent tragedy at
UCSB, and the #yesallwomen
hashtag and movement
that that started.
So what I want to
hear from you guys
is what role do you hope a show
like "Orange is The New Black"
that exist to challenge the
status quo when it comes
to women's issues can have
in making this more than just
a trending topic?
YAEL STONE: I think the
evidence was this week.
"Time Magazine"--
Laverne Cox was
the cover of "Time Magazine."
[APPLAUSE]
YAEL STONE: Like that's
a pretty exciting thing.
UZO ADOBA: Huge.
YAEL STONE: That is far
beyond the scope of the show
and probably what we
imagined the show could do,
and it's so wonderful to kind of
see that happening and changing
and this idea of the tag
line was tipping point,
like it's a moment of
change for a lot of people,
particularly for the
transgender community.
I mean, and then just the
symbol bare facts of saying,
hey, look at this cast life,
like on our call sheet.
There are women and women
and women and women and women
and how rarely that
happens, I cannot say.
Anything that I've
worked on in my life,
and I'm sure people of
much greater experience
than myself would agree that
often, the male-female balance
is not equal.
And so it's really exciting
to have those voices
and be part of something
where we're not supermodels.
We're all--
NATASHA LYONNE: Speak
for yourself, all right.
YAEL STONE: I'm sorry.
NATASHA LYONNE: All
right, thank you.
YAEL STONE: I'm sorry.
NATASHA LYONNE: Are
we on the same show?
To use-- I feel like I'm
paraphrasing something Laverne
has said, this
idea of humanizing,
there's a greater
understanding right?
That actually is the
definition of paraphrasing.
[LAUGHTER]
So I don't need any
judgment, alright?
I feel like that's kind of
happened, we put a face to-- I
was talking about
this recently, I
ran into this woman
was a judge in Texas.
I ran into her in Palm Springs
and she's talking about like,
oh I'm so happy,
I love your show.
It's so great I sentence
people all the time.
I didn't even realize
they were real.
And I was like, what
are you talking about?
This is terrifying.
I had to be gracious
which is obviously
already difficult for
me, and a challenge.
And the whole thing
was a nightmare.
I was like, wow that's so
great, that you don't realize
the people you're sentencing are
real I'm so happy to meet you.
But I do think that's part
of what this show is doing
is kind of really putting
a-- yes, I said this.
UZO ADOBA: I think also what's
exciting on our show-- all
of those things and then
just the additional layer
of the behind the
scenes on our show.
It's so great that we
have so many women,
and different types
of women represented
on the front of the
camera from race
to gender to size to
sexual orientation.
All of these faces on
a single show I think
is important to underline.
But then also once the camera's
been turned 180 degrees,
that same
representation of women
is reflected back in the
positions of Cindy Holland,
to Jenji, to the women
represented on writers,
to our visiting directors,
to Neri Tannenbaum, and Lisa
Vinnecor, and the
list goes on and on.
That this concerted effort seems
to be happening with Netflix
aligning itself with
its pioneering efforts
in original programming,
continuing on in the background
as well.
CHELSEY KANTOR: I have kept
them at bay long enough.
So can we have the
first question, Erica?
AUDIENCE: I thought
of something.
Thought of a few things.
Thank you so much for coming.
In watching the show
and just seeing you here
it's just so clear that
you're obviously very
talented actresses as you're so
different than the characters
you portray.
But what would you say about
each of your characters--
what parts of yourself do you
bring to those characters.
YAEL STONE: I spend a good deal
of time laughing at Natasha
and I find that very
easy in my real life--
NATASHA LYONNE: Thank you.
YAEL STONE: --and as Lorna.
That's what I bring in.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA LYONNE: I mean I guess
that's piggybacking on that--
YAEL STONE: Don't piggyback me.
NATASHA LYONNE: --which I enjoy
doing both on the show and off.
I don't remember the question.
I identify greatly with using
humor as a deflecting mechanism
in my life as well as Nicky's.
UZO ADOBA: I think
the thing that I'm
most like with Suzanne is the
depth with which she wants
to love-- I have loved as
deeply, that deeply before.
I didn't pee on the
floor or anything.
[LAUGHTER]
I did love that deeply.
CHELSEY KANTOR: You
just threw a pot.
UZO ADOBA: Yeah, exactly.
But I do, I think that depth of
love, I certainly can relate.
NATASHA LYONNE: And you
are loved as deeply, Uzo.
UZO ADOBA: Aww, I
love these guys.
Thanks, I really do.
AUDIENCE: So you guys obviously
have really awesome chemistry
in the show.
I'm just wondering, do you
guys also hang out afterwards?
I just have this image of like
Pennsatucky and Pornstashe
singing "My Heart Will
Go On" in karaoke.
[LAUGHTER]
YAEL STONE: That specifically
has never happened,
I don't think.
NATASHA LYONNE: Though, do we
have any real way of knowing?
[LAUGHTER]
YAEL STONE: That's so true.
And for the right price,
I'm sure it could.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA LYONNE: How
much money do you have
was actually the question.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean we do.
Like we we're here,
we're at the fancy hotel.
I came out of my
door in the morning,
we were all in our
exercise clothes
playing with my
dog in the hallway
only they were just coming
back from exercising.
And then we were like,
we'll go exercise.
So a lot of exercising
behind the cameras happening.
You wouldn't know
it necessarily.
One time Kate
Mulgrew said to me,
she said to me,
you go to the gym?
That was a really nice
thing she said to me.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway we do.
We do go to the gym.
And then we came back
from yesterday's events
and it was Yael in
my room and then
we were like jumping around
the room playing with the dog.
There's a lot of--
YAEL STONE: It's just
like babysitter's club.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA LYONNE:
--a lot of playing
with the dog and exercise.
We go eat together.
I've never seen anything
like this where we really I
think that we made choice below
the level of consciousness
early on like either this
can be a disaster with all
these women, or this can be like
a whole other level of just so
much joy and strength and all
these sort of positive new age
themes.
And we went for that one.
[LAUGHTER]
And it is terrific,
let me tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
YAEL STONE: Vagina!
Vagina!
You can say it.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
thanks for coming.
My question is about
preparation for the roles.
Prison is a really
complex place, so
what did you do to
prepare for your role
and what did you
learn that you were
surprised by that preparation?
YAEL STONE: I'm going to
slightly skew that and say
for me, each day
I have turn up, I
have a very specific thing that
I like to go through for Lorna.
Because obviously she's a little
different from me in some ways.
I like to start with
my prison underpants.
I always wear them.
They're very large granny
panties, you know them.
And then the bra
makes you breasts
go in this kind of
'50s style thing.
And once I've got them on I'm
like, alright, this can happen.
And then for me hair and
makeup is a great way in.
For some characters
it's a wonderful place
to go inside-out.
For Lorna, going outside-in
seems to work for me.
And I really enjoy
that transformation.
And the people to look
after us with hair and make
are very special people and
often under acknowledged
in a lot of these spheres.
But that transformation
is incredible.
And I often will find
from sitting down
in the chair to getting
up in the chair I'm
like oh my god I'm suddenly
Lorna, and I didn't realize.
NATASHA LYONNE: I got
by just showing up.
UZO ADOBA: My preparation,
I did my homework as far
as reading the
book, and I watch--
I used to watch a lot
of MSNBC "Lockup."
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, I love
that you like it too.
When they're in there watching
through the window and the food
all getting thrown
at-- anyway, watch it.
As far as the day
to day, I do a lot
of walking both before
and after I start work.
And usually as far as the
going in on the day to day.
That relaxation
and the meditation
of that to both let
her in and welcome her
in as well as the putting her
away at the end of the day--
putting her back on the shelf.
And depending on what the day
calls for-- sometimes a higher
shelf than others so that I can
put her away and say goodbye
to her-- I find to be very
useful in opening up the space
to allow for the music to sing.
NATASHA LYONNE: Now I want
to answer my question.
I guess what I do is think
about in prison you'd be there.
You'd be there every day,
and like when we're there--
the way we're talking about this
morning-- by the end of the six
months that it takes
us to shoot a season,
we're so beat down
and beat to a pulp.
At the beginning
of the season we
were coming off of a press
tour and hair and makeup
and, oh wow you're so great.
By the end of those six
months, we're prisoners.
We're really just exhausted and
kind of like underfed and over
sugared and just beat.
Mostly what I try to do,
and such a joy of this show
is how little they-- it doesn't
matter if you get your beauty
rest or you ate too much
salt yesterday or something,
you got three hours of sleep.
I try to really
live in that thing
about however I wake up
that morning, that's fine,
bring it to work.
Not trying to--
because if you think
about really being
in prison, everybody
has good days and bad days.
And some days you'd
wake up and you'd
be like, oh shit it's life
let me go do this thing.
And other days you'd
wake up and be like,
I really don't want
to participate today.
So I feel like I try to,
whatever the script is,
memorize my lines I already know
who she is because we've gotten
to play them for a good
amount of time now.
And then just try and
hold on to that state
and let it play into the day.
It's a way to bring
in those levels
rather than trying to manipulate
myself into a certain something
else.
I just feel like that's one of
the great joys of this show is
that we're not-- it's like
beyond cable, this show.
So it's kind of a very come
as you are kind of gig.
Like that's what is applauded
on our set is as much truth
and being as laid
bare as possible
is what's our language.
And so I feel like that's
part of what we all try to do.
AUDIENCE: Hi I'm Jonathan.
I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
My question for you guys
is, a lot of my friends act.
I used to act, and
I always wanted
to get into the business.
And for a lot of
people in my community
it's really hard to make
it, with limited resources
and not a lot of
positive support.
I was just wondering
what did you guys you
in terms of getting
into the business
and being a positive role
model for a lot of people
out there watching your show?
YAEL STONE: Well I
feel incredibly lucky.
There's a lot of gratitude.
And I know many, many
people who are deeply
talented human beings and I
think that we probably all do.
People who are really
shining lights of creativity
and sometimes we get an
incredible opportunity
like this and you
take it and you say,
thank you and you
do what you can
to bring your whole self to it.
And that's all I can say.
I don't think I have any special
magic recipe other than just
I am so grateful to be here.
So grateful to be here with you.
And to be with these women.
And to be telling such
a wonderful story.
Thank you.
UZO ADOBA: I think
definitely whatever
the area you can find
it-- to find training.
If you can't go to school, take
class or read plays and things
like this are always important
just to keep your finger
tapped in.
Maybe you're not working
on the job at the moment
but preparing for
it in some capacity.
Gratitude and recognition
of that I think always
in any area of your life
is absolutely important.
I think it one, keeps
you sturdy and faithful
that something will come.
And in saying the
something will come,
I can only speak to my
own personal experience
was when I moved to
New York to start
pursuing acting professionally.
My mom dropped me off the
train station-- my family's
from Nigeria, we're
of the Igbo tribe.
And my mom dropped me off.
She turned off the car and she
said "Uzo, just work hard."
She's like, "all I'm going to
ask you is to just work hard."
She said, "I don't
know what will come.
I don't know what will come.
I don't know when it will
come, but something will come.
I've never heard of nothing
coming from hard work."
And that has stayed
with me my entire life.
I've never heard of nothing
coming from hard work.
I heard of nothing
coming from nothing
to borrow from
Lear, "King Lear."
Nothing comes from
nothing but I mean,
I've never heard of nothing
coming from hard work.
What, the when,
the why, the how,
is less important to
the doing of the thing.
And something will come.
CHELSEY KANTOR: We have time
for one more audience question,
so you're going to be it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
so much for being here.
I was just wondering
if you could
talk about what
it's like working
on the format of Netflix and
avoiding posting spoilers
on social media or
anything like that.
Does that create
unique challenges
working on a show that is
streamed through Netflix?
NATASHA LYONNE:
What's the question?
What's it like
working for Netflix
and can you put spoilers,
is it hard not to?
YAEL STONE: The format.
NATASHA LYONNE: Yeah
I mean, it's great.
We're having such a blast.
I mean it's really
fun that it feels
like it's encouraged for
us to be as good as we can.
It's not by committee.
It's not like this
sort of watering down
the product and the
writing and like making
things as safe as possible.
And keeping them as intelligent
as they are in the first draft.
And that's a real
treasure in show business.
That's really great as far as--
it's really great because that
just kind of means
that we get to work
in a very protected
vacuum where it's
all about the sort of
creativity and integrity
and doing our best work.
There's not a lot of noise.
And as far as the
spoilers on the internet,
it can be challenging.
There are many
pictures that we take
the around throughout the
day that would be so much
fun to tell people.
But really I don't want to know.
I don't want to know things.
I don't want to know about
the end of "The Crying
Game," before I've watched it,
let me just watch "The Crying
Game."
YAEL STONE: Stop trying
to tell her the end.
Stop it.
NATASHA LYONNE: I
haven't seen it yet.
But I just want
you to not tell me
what happens at the end
of "The Crying Game."
YAEL STONE: I think the
format the way it's laid out,
it's like, here's the feast, you
can eat it as fast as you want
or as slow as you like.
And some people are like
nibble, nibble, nibble.
Other people are like [GNAWING].
I think that's a great thing.
We love choice.
That's kind of the
world we live in now.
People delight in being
like, oh my god, I
watched it all in a
row, it was amazing.
And other people
are like, I'm going
to spend the next year
watching this thing,
and only watch one
frame every night.
I think that that's really
a joyful experience.
It also means that people
get sucked into this stream.
So narrative-wise
you can tell stories
in a really fast direct way.
You're not recapping.
If a viewer wants
to go back, they
can go back in their own
time and re-watch something,
get clarification on something.
But otherwise it's just like
go, go, go, you can keep going.
And I think that
does have something
to do with the fervor
of people's excitement.
Because they've had
this experience.
It's like a Michael Barney film.
People are just in there
for eight hours just like,
my god this is my life.
So I think that the format is
a really successful format.
And it is acknowledging
that people want choice
with the way they
watch things, and they
don't want to wait every
week for that one hour.
NATASHA LYONNE: And
what you said yesterday
whatever which is
that it ends up
appealing to the highest
common denominator, rather
than that sort of
undermining the intelligence
of the audience, like
you said that yesterday.
UZO ADOBA: I agree.
I agree, I think it's true.
The way that the
format is set up,
I think it's writing for
the entire shape of a piece
rather-- and I think what we
have that's really exciting
is-- the writers
have the opportunity
to tell the stories that
they want to tell start
to finish and see
those through, rather
than writing to a response.
Does that make sense?
And that I think has been
very interesting to watch
when you allow the art to
exist fully and completed.
How people that have been,
thankfully delighting in it
in that way.
You're allowing them to
give their full voice be
it from the writing's end
and also from the performance
then that's been
really wonderful.
And that it's consumed
equally as well.
And I think yeah,
the binging element--
I think of it like Burger
King, you can have your way.
Like, really.
You can really just enjoy it
the way you want to watch it.
I don't know yet, I
haven't seen the hindrance
from having it laid
out all at once.
NATASHA LYONNE: And
there's something
I heard Jenji say
the other day, which
is this idea of there's kind
of like no small characters
in this format.
So that even if a character is
only living in little bursts
or like one scene every
two episodes or something,
the nature of watching
13 hours of something
means that character
becomes very vital.
So that idea is also
sort of exciting.
That you can just
give little flavorings
in the salt and
pepper seasoning.
YAEL STONE: Having
said that, I tried
to walk around the city
with Connie Shulman, who
plays Yoga Jones.
That's a really
interesting experience
because people are
obsessed with Yoga Jones.
And if you added
up all the time,
she's not there that often.
But that experience of just
like this full family, people
have a real sense of characters.
And it's a real sense
of depth, in what
otherwise might be a cameo.
UZO ADOBA: Yeah that's right.
Like what Natasha
was just leaning on,
when Jenji said that, I
thought that was so smart
when she said that.
Because characters that could
easily be misplaced on a series
that you roll out over
the course of 26 weeks--
because people watch it
sort of close together,
someone that popped in as a
pop of color in one episode,
suddenly now in another
season or four episodes
later or six episodes
later can have a back story
and you can track
it because you just
watched it three hours ago.
CHELSEY KANTOR: It's
almost like a great book.
You can either read it
all the way through,
or you could read a
chapter at a time,
but it builds like
a great story.
UZO ADOBA: It's very Dickensian
in that way, as well.
The way that we-- "A Tale of
Two Cities," where somebody you
meet in the beginning,
you think but they
have such an important--
Charles Darcy suddenly
is so-- that's the most
important character
in the whole way.
CHELSEY KANTOR: We're
going to wrap it up
and I want to give each of
you one sentence to describe
what makes season two great.
Just one phrase to describe
YAEL STONE: I did a stunt.
CHELSEY KANTOR: Just brain dump.
NATASHA LYONNE:
Turn down for what?
[LAUGHTER]
There's a lot of-- I got to
meet a lot of women this season.
UZO ADOBA: What makes
season two great?
[GASP] That's my sentence.
[LAUGHTER]
CHELSEY KANTOR: Let's give it
up for them thank you so much.
"Orange is the New Black,"
June 6th on Netflix.
Thank you so much.
NATASHA LYONNE: We have
some questions for you guys
if you don't mind staying after.
CHELSEY KANTOR: The after show.
YAEL STONE: You're
in heaps of trouble.
NATASHA LYONNE: Everybody's
in a lot of trouble.
UZO ADOBA: Do you guys all
have to go back to work now?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
UZO ADOBA: Oh.
NATASHA LYONNE: And
how many more hours
do you have to be at work?
UZO ADOBA: I felt
like it's like to be
like school, like an
assembly and then--
CHELSEY KANTOR: Like
where's the bell.
UZO ADOBA: Yeah, exactly.
[MUSIC - REGINA SPEKTOR, "YOU'VE
GOT TIME"]